a palestinian teenager has died after
allegedly being attacked by israeli
soldiers
the incident happened in the west bank
on sunday when the 18 year old and his
friend
were chased by troops the victim's
father claims that the soldiers
beat his son to death
my son the martyr was killed in cold
blood when he wasn't going to fight
israelis or anything
his friend's car broke down and he went
to help him then the israeli soldiers
followed him
my son didn't know anything about the
area he went to so he was driving around
looking for his friend
so the soldiers followed him and then
started beating him
until they killed him without any reason
he wasn't carrying a weapon or anything
else to fight them with
he was a peaceful citizen going to help
his friend
well the israeli army does say that the
teenager tripped over and hit his head
while being chased and that
his death was caused by a head injury
the soldiers were sent to the area
after reports of stones being thrown at
an army vehicle
the palestinian health ministry confirms
that the teenager had been severely
beaten
before arriving at the hospital the only
other witness to what happened was his
friend
he reportedly fled the scene when the
israeli soldiers gave chase
the palestinian authorities are now
demanding an international probe
while the bulls boys family are still
contemplating
their loss
[Music]
this area utma is a peaceful and stable
area everyone is occupied with their
work
and their own business killing the young
mata amer ahmed is a tragedy
he was the only help and the aid to his
father who has multiple health issues
because our son's life isn't worthless
when i spent my life and lost my health
raising my son to be a man and to feed
his family then i lose him and attend
his funeral
that doesn't make any sense
you